e3 2022 is officially dead and xbox game
pass might be getting a family plan
e3 2022 has been cancelled previously
planes had been announced to host a
digital only event instead of the
typical physical event but the group
that runs it the esa has now confirmed
that the show will not take place in any
form a spokesperson for the esa told
venturebeat that e3 will return in 2023
with a quote reinvigorated showcase that
celebrates new and exciting video games
and industry innovations the esa also
confirmed that e3 2023 will be held in
los angeles not some other city e3 2019
was the last edition of the show to host
an in-person event all forms of what
would have been e3 2020 were cancelled
while e3 2021 was held as an online
event gamespot is currently attempting
to confirm with the esa what's happening
this year in regards to e3 while e3 2022
may not be going ahead jeff keeley's
annual summer game fest is coming back
this year though there are no details
yet regarding the specifics of the show
that said keeley tweeted a winky face
just after news broke that e3 2022 might
not be happening this year which is
interesting the reported cancellation of
e3 2022 comes as other video game
industry events return to in-person
gatherings pax east is going forward in
boston in april while gdc 2022 took
place earlier in march attendance for
gdc 2022 was down significantly from
previous years and kovit is surely
playing a role in that for months i've
been like wow this is going to be my
first year in games media helping to
cover e3
i guess not
in other news hot off the heels of
playstation announcing a shake-up to its
ps plus subscription xbox game pass is
reportedly going to offer a family plan
option later this year for its
subscribers according to a report from
windows central microsoft has wanted to
create a family plan for a while but
internally there were issues that needed
to be discussed such as how royalties
would be handed out and how third-party
publishers would be compensated for
subscribers who weren't on single user
plans it now looks like microsoft has
the details hashed out and is ready to
announce them later this year the family
plan will reportedly use microsoft's
family account system already in place
for office 365 and up to five players
within the same country can share an
entire library on one single xbox game
pass family plan subscription it seems
to be a higher paying tier but it will
still be cheaper than the total amount
of having to pay for five separate ones
individually though exact pricing
details are not yet known additionally
it's unknown whether there will be
separate family plans for xbox game pass
and pc game pass or if the family plan
is an exclusive perk for xbox game pass
ultimate subscribers and game pass isn't
the only thing changing soon battlefield
2042 will receive substantial map
changes in the future based on community
feedback with the first of those changes
arriving as part of the game's first
season in a new blog post battlefield
community lead adam freeman outlined all
the feedback dice has gathered from the
games community and the changes it will
be making as a result with most of them
initially revolving around 2042's
renewal and kaleidoscope maps fans have
complained about the number of issues on
these maps ranging from the distance
between objectives being too long the
lack of cover or objects to break the
line of sight lack of clear paths
between objectives and the maps feeling
too clean players have also complained
about the game's
128 player modes feeling too chaotic all
those concerns are being addressed and
will be coming in the near future the
vehicle changes to the game's 128 player
modes will come in battlefield 2042's
next update but the more substantial map
changes for kaleidoscope and renewal
will be a part of the first season dice
will be updating the rest of 2042's
launch maps with much of the same
feedback in mind but those changes won't
be coming until season 2. let me know in
the comments if you still play
battlefield 2042 and then when you're
done go follow me over on twitter it's
my birthday and i can use just a little
more clout see you tomorrow
you